[Music]
let's go to larry in
tallahassee
i just that you have to sing tallahassee
larry
all right uh well no i'm a poor gators
fan and i can't sing so no actually i'm
a grown up and i don't have to sing
tallahassee idiot
thanks larry thanks
thanks for playing along
so what's up dude
how much hey thanks for having me on um
i've been wanting to say this for a
while but long time listener first time
caller so super excited to uh to jump on
the phone here with you today dude
nobody ever says that on my show thanks
for thanks for i think you're the first
person to say that thanks man made my
heart feel good
i love being at first um
hey so here i'll jump right into it um
my wife and i sold our business back in
april uh essentially to our largest
customers at that time
did you all make the killing working
what's that did y'all make a joke you'll
make a killing on it did you crush it
yeah yeah it was great it was a
seven-figure exit and we've been ramsey
fans for a long time
congrats man yeah
yeah it was a big big big deal in our
world does uh does millionaire air taste
different than regular personnel
i still drive the same truck i still
drive live in the same house we're the
same clothes and we still bring our
lunch to work so dude you are my hero
man i'm telling you good for you brother
good for you all right so you sold your
business in april you're millionaires
what's up
so we sold the business um
to a very large private equity-owned
company that part of the deal part of
the reason why we were an acquisition
target was because we fit in with their
their larger
um strategy that they're executing on
over the next several years so
um we sold in april uh we kind of hit
the ground running and now we're six
months into this
and
my wife are kind of looking up and and
just exhausted and really not sure what
the future is in my entire
adult life i've i've been an
entrepreneur i've started other
businesses i've never had an exit like
this one um or exit at all the other
ones just kind of
you know failed but this one worked out
um
and now you know we're now we're kind of
looking at each other and i don't have
for the first time spend 17 years of my
you know career i don't have a clear
path forward or a clear vision for
really what the future looks like i'm
you know i've got an opportunity or
position that i'm in right now
um you know i'm working with people that
are way more educated than i am that
that they're leading you know other
business units within this large
organization there's some big stuff that
they're looking to accomplish over the
next several years and it's just
um
daunting exhausting and we're trying to
figure out what the future is going to
look like for for you know our family
as it relates to career and even just
you know what that looks like so we're
really struggling with some of that
clarity and um
yeah last night i i kind of said well
screw it i'll go ahead and or sorry two
days ago i i said well screw it i'll go
ahead and uh write in the john doloni
show and kelly called me and so i
appreciate any guidance that you can
provide well number one man
congratulations on your successes and it
sounds like you got hit in the mouth a
few times before that and you got back
off the canvas created something pretty
special that had a lot of value
and
somebody bought it from dude
congratulations that's resilience and
that is grinding it out and there's this
um really ugly picture of a
quote-unquote millionaire that's out
there which is somebody who
sits around and just drinks mai tais all
day and inherits money and it just grows
on trees for them and you're somebody
that ground it out and then you sold it
and you didn't change your life man you
got back in the truck and went back to
work the next day
um so congratulations all around man
that's integrity and its character and
that's that's i'm glad to know there's
folks like you out there dude that's
awesome your inspiration to me and
everybody around me
um thanks
so
lots of of angles we could take here
um
here's where i'd love to start
just because something's a cool
opportunity
and has an opportunity for growth and
has an opportunity to do big things and
huge things and exciting things
doesn't mean that it's right for you
and doesn't mean that you have to do it
you can't like an old dating analogy is
you can be absolutely in love with
somebody
and think they are wonderful
and absolutely know they are not the
person you're supposed to marry
those things are not all mutually
exclusive
and same thing when it comes to work
you can really be exciting about the
opportunity and the potential and yada
yada
but you're a guy who builds businesses
from scratch and grinds it out and has a
vision and a mission and you see it
through
and you may not be
fulfilled in the private equity world
where the goal is to make other people
really really really rich
and then to move on like that like a
like an alien ship that just comes in
absorbs all the resources from a planet
and then goes to the next planet right
you know what i mean that may not be
your jam
and that's totally okay but you and i
were taught
that
the job that pays us the most the one
that has the most excitement and the
most growth opportunity that's the job
we have to take that's what's next for
us
and by the way does it suck working at
your own company that you're not the
boss of anymore that can't be fun
yeah it's it's been a challenge and you
know
i looked at it just like i tried to look
at everything you know my both my wife
and i are veterans we didn't finish our
college degree we kind of jumped right
into the workforce so i look at this as
an educational opportunity to work for
a large organization take advantage of
the opportunities to learn um
and i think we're having a hard time
just even even making decisions where
we're at what the future is i think one
of the things that's kind of echoed in
my mind i've heard you say it a few
times but
you know you go with you right we've had
over the last
over the last 24 months even just
leading up to it it's been a whirlwind
we've got four kids we have an eleven
and a half year old a nine year old a 19
month old and a six week old
[Laughter]
larry lead with that
god almighty dude homie you're fried
fried yeah
okay so hey listen
so
which branch of the military are you in
marine corps
so
there's some mythology around basic
training in the marine corps right
it's for real
right and you learned some stuff about
yourself right it was a good learning
opportunity
that's right yeah would you like to just
keep doing that forever
no no it sucks it's not designed forever
it's not fun correct so tell me if i'm
accurate you how long have you been out
of the military
uh it's been a while man
um call it 15 years
okay so let's backtrack your life a
little bit
you're in the marines
which is
strong to quite strong on the stressor
meter
um you were in right as we were getting
into some of these conflicts
so
okay you're in them and then ta-da we
have a baby
i'm a dad
and then i roll out i roll right into
the workforce i try to create something
from nothing
there is successes there's big failures
i'm back in it let's have another kid
and then
whoopsie we'll have another kid and then
super whoopsie do we have another
another kid so now we have a thousand
kids and then the stress of
oh my gosh this business is working
which is a different kind of stress this
thing's actually running and gunning and
creating value
oh my gosh and someone wants to buy it
how long do those conversations was a
year of conversations and negotiations
they actually went on for a little over
a year close to two years okay started
having conversations and covid put a
stop to it so we pivoted real hard into
other
other areas of the business that started
to grow and take traction and
and then they came back and then we had
coveted outbreak we had a team member
pass away we had a lot of stuff happen
in a real short period of time and so
it's the constant
highest of highs lowest of lows
fight or flight
yeah and now we're trying to figure out
what's normal look like and that's
that's really where i know we're
struggling is to and we just live in
this tornado of sorts
trying to figure out what the
that's why we've hesitated on doing
anything rash because we realize that
when we recognize that we're in this
tornado so
weaving and going into another tornado
is not necessarily going to help unless
we can figure out how to how to live in
the world that we're in right now so i i
there's a third option you've given
yourself two
and there's a third option
you've been on fight or flight for 20
years
yeah and there comes a point are you 45
37 37 okay
your body is getting is redlining on you
and it is beeping at you because you
haven't changed the oil in a long time
and you're looking at the metrics part
four kids that are probably pretty
pretty good because they got good
parents
you got seven figures in a payout
you've got good jobs in a in a
corporation now you don't even have
college degrees and you're like yeah
we're kind of running a scam here and
it's awesome
and so you're looking at the metrics i
bet you guys have a nice house
um you've got your metrics that look
good
and it's like looking at the
speedometer my car is still going 100
miles an hour so things are going great
but those lights on the dashboard are
flashing at you brighter and brighter
and brighter so i want to offer you a
third option which is
taking a break for a minute
and that break can look like me and my
wife are going to go on a three-month
vacation
i mean our three-week vacation a
two-month vacation
hey new company we need a break
we're gonna step out and if they say
well you're fired then then pay us out
we are millionaires pay us out
and my guess is they won't but they
might or maybe a two-week vacation
and you take yeah i don't know you got a
six-month a six-week-old so y'all are in
it with that one
but you get babysitters you get someone
to support it and y'all go breathe for
the first time in 20 years
and you can't
um
you know dave ramsey talks a lot about
you know the gazelle intensity the
gazelle running from the lion
there's a reason why our bodies shift
function away from
wanting to be sexually intimate
wanting to
eat well
wanting to
think rationally or being able to think
rationally because the body's just
saying survive survive survive survive
survive
and what i want you guys to do
is to breathe
new air
for the first time and
since you were a kid who went into the
marine corps
and then from that place where you guys
have gone
whoo
then you can say
what do we want to do
now
do we want to start a new business do we
want to invest in something do we want
to just take regular jobs at starbucks
and just relax and find each other for a
year what do we want to do
and starbucks for you two will be every
bit of learning opportunity
as your corporate fancy pants job right
now that's that's that's killing you
because you're not a corporate
fancy-pants iconic guy and you feel
stupid for walking away from it but
that's just not you man
yeah
and so
you can't do the hard work to think
about what do i want
while you're still running for your life
yeah what is it when you think of
just not working for a season do you
have the money to do that
we do yeah we do what would that even
look like for you
it's uh
we've thought we've talked about it um
i mean it's candidly it's terrifying
i don't know why is it because is it
terrifying because of value is it
terrifying because you're scared to look
in the mirror and be peaceful what was
it terrifying
it's probably terrifying just to stop
and
you have to stop and almost have
too much quiet and you'll be forced to
look in the mirror in a sense and
there's
yeah and there's a lot that's happened
over the last you know 20 years to your
point that i've i've just kept running
and running and yeah never really
stopped lots of trauma lots of the so
the the the
in the counseling world we say we call
it leakage
and
you can deal with it on your terms or
your body will deal with it and it
usually is at the most inopportune time
possible
but it will get dealt with in some some
way
here's my recommendation i would love to
see you two not quit anything yet i'd
love to see y'all go get a marriage
counselor not because y'all are
dysfunctional or broken
but somebody who can begin to inject
ideas
and recommendations for
what does
peace look like what are things we work
towards what do we want to do and
they'll just not a counselor like we
need to fix something but y'all got a
six week old y'all are so in it man
how can we even learn how to dream again
how do we even learn what peace is you
haven't had peace in two decades and my
guess is you probably didn't have it
before that either peace may be a whole
new mission for you
and that doesn't mean you don't work
your butt off it doesn't mean you don't
stress and find a new career where you
are grinding and running that's not what
it is
but peace is when you can
whoo smile
when you can have a
series of practices or behaviors where
somebody around you dies that you love
that you can mourn that and grieve that
and then get back on the horse and
grieve it as you're walking
where you cannot work out one day and
know that's going to be all right
i'm going to do a couple things for you
i'm going to send you
my buddy ken coleman's new book from
paycheck to purpose it's the seven steps
on getting clear about what you want to
do next
i'm gonna send you a free copy of that
book so stay on the line here and i'm
gonna send you two one for you and one
for your wife
um two copies of his new
um
it's an assessment for folks to figure
out i'm at this stage of my life what do
i even wanna do next and it's a good
place for you to start i'm going to send
two of those to you for free also okay
and i want you and your wife to take
those and look at each other and be like
what do we want to do
oh my gosh and here's what i want you to
look at i want you to look at peace i
want you to look at healing i want you
to look at learning what to do next
learning how to look at that dude in the
mirror
those are your new mission those aren't
soft skills those are new
tasks that you need to learn you need
these are hard skills that you need to
learn how to do you didn't know how to
change a tire on a truck in the middle
of desert you had to learn that real
fast you had to learn how to pick up a
50 cal and turn it you had to learn how
to do that real fast you're going to
learn how to do this one now okay these
are just new skills you're going to be
curious you're going to be gentle with
yourself you're going to fail and fall
on your face but you're gritting you get
back up you're going to practice these
things man
and then you've heard me say this a
thousand times i'ma say it a thousand
times more
you and your wife are going to
completely excavate just like the 9-1-1
site the the downtown new york you're
going to excavate the whole thing
we built an awesome business we sold it
for seven figures
now what we're in our 30s we can retire
and just move to the mountains
we can create a coffee shop and just
carry coffee around to elderly neighbors
we can create a who a lawn bed who knows
we can do anything
we're gonna rebuild something new we're
gonna learn new ways to talk to each
other to ourselves
what do we want and i don't know if
you've ever answered that question for
yourself what do i want but now is the
new season we're going to practice
asking yourself that question now does
that sound terrifying or exciting
because it excites me just talking about
it
uh no it does sound exciting and that's
you know we've
we kind of had those conversations
leading up to it as we started dreaming
about okay this is actually happening
and what's the what's the world going to
look like for the
the larry family um you know in the
future and
um
and then we just got in it and it's just
like a we've just been stuck on this
train that we used to be the conductors
of and now we're just a passenger
and we're rolling um so yeah so
discovering a way to get off that train
and
find out what the future looks like is
exciting that's awesome man all right so
i'm gonna send you these tools so hang
on the line here and kelly will get them
for you and
i want you guys to call a marriage
counselor and you're going to be
um a song to a marriage counselor's ears
you're going to call and say hey we're
doing great we want to learn some tools
on how to dream together for the future
it looks like we've been running for 25
years for 20 years non-stop 24 7 365. we
just sold a business
we we
we pretended to be corporate people and
we hate it
and we want to know what's next we want
to we want to learn some some new tools
for how to dream
and then i want you all to lean into it
and by the way you got a six week six
week old a two-year-old
it's gonna be bonkers for a few years
and that's okay you all been through
worse you've been through crazier and
the world is better because larry you
all two are in it um thank you so so
much for the call